beautiful night in baltimore it's game
two of the double header between the
orioles and the marlins
i can't a time in major league baseball
history of being at a stadium and and
that team being the away team but it's
their stadium it was almost bizarre to
hear the pa announcer just say you know
welcome to visiting orioles welcome to
2020.
let's start the insanity we're focused
on josh a here to start this ball game
in what we expect to be a bullpen game
for the marlins they only have to cover
seven
and a ground ball to third that's eddie
alvarez across to brian anderson who is
able to keep his toe on the back he
looks like don mattingly over there at
first base and this is first big league
start a little bit of payback there
right
so that's what it's like to save uh an
infielder in an error asher
wojciechowski one start on the year five
innings gave up five runs four were
earned struck out seven walk two and
that was against the yankees jonathan vr
to start the offense for the marlins
here is john bertie
rips this one to left field gonna get
down for a base hit
bertie can fly so can vr he is being
held at third base it's a double for
john bertie and the marlins offense off
to a quick start one gone in the inning
runners at second and third base
for aguilar
in the air to deep right field should be
deep enough to score a run santander
makes the play vr will score
also moving up to third is john bernie
and the marlins have a one to nothing
lead
and the road home fake crowd into it
marlon's on the board first we travel
well that's right
we travel well
look at that even some some marlins
themed graphics and animations
one to nothing marlins anderson the
batter here's the pitch to brian and he
hits it off the end of the bat and rolls
it through the right side that's going
to cash in john birdie two to nothing
marlins on an opposite field hit by
brian anderson start of the second
inning from camden yards sierra the
center fielder way back joyce and right
field in a little more
ripped through the box into center field
base hit for nunez so lead off single
for renato
two on two down brings up the number
eight hitter andrew velasquez
and this is golfed out towards shallow
left center field dickerson merging
along with vr but the left fielder makes
the call of a catch and the inning
concludes the orioles again leave
runners on base they hand the ball over
to sterling sharp who is set to make his
major league debut a rule five pick from
washington in 2019
2-1 pitch to mullins
get hard on the ground but right to the
second baseman
birdie fires over one down
so santander anthony struck out in the
first inning sharp ready 2-1 home
santander swings and it's a soft roll up
the third base side coming in with the
low toss but able to get there in time
is alvarez and the 5-3 put out in the
inning nothing going for the orioles
house here who stays out
as the 2-0 comes home vr swings and he
pops up a ball down past third base on
it is valenca and as he trails into the
track and then arches backwards he's got
it and one retired in the bottom of the
third that's a pretty tough play for
balayka he he got woj housekeeping out
there
because it was way too far forward
with the nod kick and the 1-2 pitch
dickerson backs away but he's caught
looking on a fastball from wojciechowski
and it's another one two three inning
sterling sharp is back out again 0-1 to
iglesia swings in a sharp line down the
left side this will roll into the corner
iglesias rounds first takes a glance up
and will trot into second base as corey
dickerson has to dig this one out of the
corner of the outfield again a leadoff
double for jose glacious
brian moran will take over
again with two outs and jose iglesias
standing on at second base the o2 pitch
to haste a swing and a miss pitch was
elevated hayes went after he's down on
strikes for levarnway he's at first and
here's eddie alvarez to the play 3-2 to
alvarez and a swing up top he's empty
striking out for asher wojciechowski one
away
payoff pitch coming
and vr lines a base it into right center
field lavarnway on his way to third
he will get there standing and the
marlins have him on the corners with two
outs
and now wojciechowski will see if he can
get birdie and bring this inning to an
end birdie swings and it's a bounce over
to third base felaka cross and it's in
time he gets out of the inning no runs
come home for the marlins so instep says
tarpley stares in for the sign
santander is it second severino is at
first base
a swinging a high chopper left side and
this one sneaks into left field rounding
third base and coming home is santander
he makes it in hayes is on base and the
orioles have their first run since the
eighth inning on sunday against tampa
bay
brian holliday is going to pinch hit
brian holliday former backup receiver
with the marlins hits the ball on the
ground at second they get one the throw
onto first base they get two
how about that one pitch and uh
the double play ball nicely done just
like that you only have one out left
one
is in the air
right field moving over
making the catch and ending the ball
game it's a marlins win